Imagine what it would be like if you left the Earth for an entire year.
Away from your friends, your family, everything you love and care about.
Two of Earth's bravest are making that sacrifice right now.
They've traveled beyond our atmosphere for a yearlong stay...
...aboard the International Space Station.
Here they'll study the effects of prolonged weightlessness on the human body.
Their discoveries will allow humans to travel farther into space than ever before.
The conditions are harsh, the risk is great,...
...but the potential payoff is huge.
We could stay on Earth, but that's not who we are.
We're scientists and we're explorers.
We'll always venture into the unknown and seek to expand our knowledge.
One day soon, humans will step foot on Mars.
And it's the science being conducted today aboard the International Space Station...
...that will help us get there.
We explore the universe because we must,...
...because humankind's future doesn't belong on Earth alone.